morning Kohler no no no my good chap
it's professor over today I believe
we'll take a look at some of the
mysteries of we where I got a puzzle for
you yes smashing not going to take so
long dead at your stories caller I see
you want to know how many of my stories
you can edit in one week that no beads
no I'm saying it takes a long time to
edit your stories ever to spell check
thank you once again professor Kohler
for that enlightening waste of
everyone's time but he's right it is
time to take a look at we wear Nintendo
has just launched its games on demand
service for we in Japan so let's take a
look at some of the downloadable launch
titles easily the biggest launch title
is Final Fantasy crystal chronicles my
life as a king it's also the most
expensive at about 15 bucks it's not
your typical Final Fantasy game it's a
sim style town simulation where you play
the part of a child king who has to make
his castle town livable for its
inhabitants you'll send them off on
adventures and they'll go into dungeons
and bring you back resources which you
can then spend on building new buildings
which in turn bring you more subjects
etc we're having a good time with my
life is a king so far so if the concept
interests you this is probably worth
your money I really don't know what
Medical Board ever thought it was a good
idea to grant Mario his medical license
I mean all he really seems to do is
fling unmarked suppositories into a vat
full of what appear to be aliens anyway
Nintendo has revived it's classic
falling stuff puzzle game for Wii where
you can play doctor Mario the normal way
matching the colored viruses to the
pills or you can play a new Wii mote
version in which up to four players can
use the pointer to drag the capsules
into place I tried the games online mode
out against a random Japanese woman who
kicked my ass so we know it works
konami's first we where game is Saku
Saku animal panic ok Sokka means fence
all right it doesn't mean what you're
thinking you play the part of a farmer
who has to pen in his escaped animals
you can build as many fences as you like
just as long as each subdivision
contains only one kind of animal this is
actually pretty fun if you run into an
animal you get killed and they move
randomly so there's this risk reward
gameplay do you forge ahead into
dangerous territory with your fence and
risk dying or play it safe the better a
job you do the better your score at the
end of the level now here's an example
of the low end of wiiware games no
you're not looking at an unfinished beta
this is actually what lon post looks
like it's a real head-scratcher of a
puzzle game in which you try to fit
these oddly shaped pieces of plastic
into a rectangular container but
honestly it's not worth the whopping 10
bucks they want you to pay for it as the
presentation is really low rent know if
you want to see a wiiware game that's
definitely worth the money we have to
turn 20 kiraku ping-pong this game
really hits the spot for we wear it
makes good use of the wiimote to play
ping-pong it's got multiplayer although
only for two players it's got four
characters three stages and a few
minigames that you practice your aim
sure it's not the deepest game around
but unlike those crappy $20 wii games
that we covered on a previous episode of
game life this one only costs five bucks
plus it's adorable just look at their
cute faces
we can't say that we whereas launch has
been entirely successful and I'm not
just talking about the fact that some of
the games are clearly half-assed where
the demos you can't try a game before
you buy it and if you get stuck with a
lemon you can't exactly take it back to
the store also where's the hardcore
gamer content Nintendo should realize
that we where is a really good
opportunity for them to bring back some
of their classic franchises forgotten
ones like punch out or kid icarus
hopefully we'll get a more well-rounded
launch lineup when we where comes to
north america on may 12
you